but you know i keep thinking it's like
you know this was the same time i was
doing probably smallville and you're
doing buffy and angel
and all this stuff and i don't know what
it's like to be a woman i'll never know
what it's like to be a woman and it's
hard i could tell how hard it is
and you how people look at you
and what was it the the thing that kind
of the straw that broke the camel's back
that felt you felt like
this is toxic like that i mean there's
probably little things along the way but
what what is it that
is it you know because i'm not really i
don't know a lot about this
other than it was a toxic work
environment and a lot of people
supported you and said yes it was and i
was like oh wow and i don't really know
the inside scoop
other than um i know some issues when
you were pregnant and things like that
um and it just sounded awful but i just
wanted to hear it from you
yeah um i'm too keen talking about it
because
i think i think honestly
i was really descriptive with my letter
for that reason you know and so like
when it all kind of happened
i was getting a lot of invitations from
you know like the today show or the view
or like
all these people gail king you know
calling to
have a conversation about it and i
really wanted to be clear
that um this wasn't about publicity
this isn't about a publicity tour to
kind of like
you know share my air my gree you know
like
laundry or whatever in the sense that
it's a that it's
because people and the world at large
based on my own social media um
are cynical of that kind of stuff you
know they think that that's why you're
saying it you know they think that
that's
what's happening and i think um
you know it's disappointing to hear that
that's where the head goes um
but i'm sure in some cases that has
happened so
it's fair but um i just really
feel like i said everything that i
needed to say
and it took me two weeks to write that
letter
and every word choice you know i had a
typo in there which still begs me
but like what was the typo you worry
about a typo people don't worry about
you don't know but like
it literally like i worked so hard
editing it crafting it
saying this not saying that what do i
want to say
what you know what instances should i
choose to say
like i really said
everything i could have possibly wanted
to say on the subject
there and it was very articulate i mean
it really spoke volumes
and did it feel like it was like an
elephant
out of the room like or you know the
monkey off your back like you felt like
once you did it it felt really just good
to get it out there because it's
something that had been bottling up for
so many years
um actually it was really stressful it
was really stressful
the two weeks knowing that it was coming
that i was crafting it
then when i had to push post that was
really stressful i thought literally i
was gonna lose my bowels in my bed
um
um like quite literally i had gurglies
and you know and i think that's kind of
like
two why i had to do it because i knew
how it made me feel and i knew i was
taking a really big
really big risk by saying this because
you know i go to cons all the time
and you know it's a great deal of my
income and these days and
i was really putting myself in a
position to alienate
my fandom and speaking out against
the creator of my show where i go to
these conventions and people walk with
t-shirts on their backs saying
like joss whedon is my god so i was
really afraid of insulting them
offending them alienating them
and i really had no idea that co-workers
were gonna like i
really never imagined sarah saying
anything
or like i was really
really just as shocked as everybody like
you just yeah everybody
just your work when your co-workers were
saying then you're like wow
i i did not see that i i thought maybe
deadline
would pick it up i had no idea you had
no expectations you just thought i want
to do this
because i want to do this and no i
wanted to do for ray
i think it's easier to
advocate for other people than for
yourself and i knew certainly 20 years
ago that wasn't an option
so well i i appreciate it 20 years later
that the same person was doing the same
things
you know i i had grown um
i had met ray at a con we became very
good friends through a con
and you know that's how how it all how
our conversation
kind of started and how our
how then like three months later he last
summer
he said what he said and then he like
once in my name on on social media and
then i was like really under pressure
and i wanted to do something behind the
scenes you know
in my own time yeah and when he
was let go from the cyborg role
cyborg role i'd
that was